[Musique]
bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau journal as
d'informations locales nous sommes le
mercredi 5 janvier voici les titres de
ce journal
la france préside désormais le conseil
de l'union européenne et ce pour une
durée de six mois une première depuis
2008 le point sur son rôle ses missions
avec elle et référent yvelinois des
questions européennes
demain 6 janvier ce sera le jour de
l'épiphanie événements que vous
célébrerez sûrement autour d'une galette
cette direction la boulangerie la flûte
de chopin à houdan près de 2000 galette
ils sont préparés chaque année en
janvier et puis le tirage pour les
huitièmes de finale de coupe de france
de football s'est dévoilé le club
national de versailles y participe pour
la première fois il recevra dans les
prochains jours un club de ligue 2 le fc
toulouse et puis nous vous parlerons
également des lanceurs spatiaux
développer dans les yvelines et du paris
nice qui s'élancera de mantes la ville
[Musique]
et pour débuter ce journal nous vous
proposons de découvrir une technologie
spatiale la start up bin cyrus space
services est spécialisé dans la
conception de lanceur spatial
réutilisable c'est un produit utilisé
pour la mise en orbite des satellites
pour l'heure dans une phase de
développement le premier vol inaugural
est prévue pour 2025 direction le
laboratoire aux loges en josas avec
nicolas landry et laura légaux
voici sirius 1 le space x des yvelines
un lanceur spatial réutilisable conçu
par la start-up sirius paye service is
une technologie en cours de
développement dans le laboratoire de
cette entreprise basée aux loges en
josas
c'est un lanceur qui fait environ 20
mètres de haut un diamètre de 7 mètres
et qui pèsera à 20 tonnes au décollage
on voit ici le premier étage qui est un
étage qui comporte neuf moteurs
c'est un danseur qui fonctionne à
l'oxygène liquide et au méthane est au
dessus on peut voir la coiffe et c'est à
cet endroit que seront accommodés les
satellites qui seront lancées par ce
lanceur en ce moment nous sommes en
train de tester la plaque d'injection de
ce moteur à eau sous pression sur le
banc d'essai qui est situé juste
derrière moi
[Musique]
ce banc d'essai permet de tester la
plaque d'injection du moteur une
expérience réalisée avec de l'eau et de
l'air comprimé à haute pression sirius
paye service is a été créée en avril
2020 aujourd'hui 35 collaborateurs
composent cette société une levée de
fonds de 3 millions d'euros en 2021 pour
pouvoir développer une gamme de trois
lanceurs spatiaux s'élancèrent vont
servir à mener des charges utiles des
thés satellite comprise entre 1 et 500
kg dans des orbites différentes donc
désormais comprise entre 2 700 km de la
société a été à deux valeurs clés on a
pour le but de proposer deux lanceurs
peu cher on adéquation avec le marché et
aussi des lanceurs 100% réutilisables
interne pour diminuer l'empreinte
carbone majoritairement dans un premier
temps on se concentre sur marché
européen dans un second temps va lire
rapidement vers le marché - marché aux
états unis et côté chine aussi asie
avec le recrutement de 20 personnes
supplémentaires dans les six prochains
mois l'objectif est fixé à 100
collaborateurs fin 2022 une usine de
production devrait ouvrir au deuxième
semestre 2022 sur le plateau de saclay
le premier vol d'un lanceur spatial
sirius est prévue début 2011 25 depuis
le centre spatial de kourou en guyane
saint lambert des bois communes
d'eysines situé en vallée de chevreuse a
été retenus pour expérimenter les radars
sono installée ce mardi 4 janvier cette
expérimentation va durer deux ans
objectif lutter contre les nuisances
sonores des véhicules et des capteurs
permettront de contrôler leurs niveaux
d'émissions la verbalisation devrait
démarrer courant 2022 montant de
l'amendé en cas de dépassement du seuil
autorisé 135 euros et puis un point à
présent sur la vaccination contre la
copie de 19 depuis le 22 décembre la
vaccination est ouverte à l'ensemble des
enfants de 5 à 11 ans pour l'heure huit
centres de vaccination accueille vos
enfants dont les yvelines le complexe
sportif de la vallée à
bonnières-sur-seine le gymnase richard
mique à versailles le centre maurice
ravel centre commercial westfield vélizy
2 à vélizy villacoublay
la salle du colombier à
saint-germain-en-laye l'espace gérard
philipe à sartrouville l'espace jean
racine saint rémy les chevreuse et puis
le vélodrome nationale à montigny le
bretonneux à plus d'informations sur le
site de l'agencé régionale de santé ile
de france
[Musique]
je vous en parlais en titre la france a
pris la présidence du conseil de l'union
européenne depuis début janvier pour une
durée de six mois on fait le point sur
son rôle et sur ses missions avec vous
paraît elle est chère nord bonsoir
bonsoir vous êtes un représentant et
binoy du parlement européen mais vous
êtes détaché à à bazoches sur guyonne
dont la maison jean monnet le conseil et
de l'union européenne 1 dispose d'une
présidente tout d'une présidence pardon
tournante la france prend donc la
présidence du conseil de l'union
européenne tous les 13 ans à peu près la
dernière fois c'était en 2008 quelles
responsabilités ça implique pour l'état
qui préside concrètement
alors c'est surtout
un rôle administratif
pays doit jouer le rôle d'un arbitre
entre les vingt sept pays de l'union
européenne on travaille sur des dossiers
des lois ouvert avant la présidence c la
slovénie hier pour la france et après
c'est mon pays la république tchèque qui
va prendre la présidence en juillet
et les pouvoirs n'est pas vraiment
immense
mais permet de gérer des thèmes qui sont
importants pour la france par exemple
l'immigration défense économie ni et
surtout
l'occasion de mettre l'europe à leur
honneur de son propre pays
et donner la visibilité de l'union
européenne à l'extérieur chaque pays
peut donner sa vision d'europe un peu au
dossier
et il va il faut savoir que c'est
toujours une présidence tournante alors
chaque six mois dans les conseils il
faut pas mélanger le conseil de l'union
européenne et le conseil européen parce
que les conseils européens ça c'est où
les chefs d'état se réunissent quatre
fois par an alors et maquereau est là
avec avant ça c'était un gala merkel les
autres maintenance et olaf scholz et les
autres chefs des pays de l'union
européenne et la
c c'est un peu une autre chose parce que
la présidence dure deux ans et demi en
président fixe alors c'est surtout dans
le travail quotidien où la france
maintenant est un peu m de long
justement vous parlez de montrer un peu
sa vision de l'europe pour l'état qui
préside emmanuel macron souhaite mettre
l'accent notamment sur plusieurs axes la
taxe carbone aux frontières ou encore
l'adoption d'un salaire minimum en
europe qu'est ce qu'on peut attendre par
exemple comme avancer sur ces sujets
je pense la france
s'est par contre par contre qu'on a un
petit pays comme la slovénie ou même mon
pays la république tchèque on n'a pas
nécessairement
licence sur les thèmes si fort que si
c'est un grand pays comme la france et
si la france et met d'accord avec
l'allemagne on a déjà un poids sur
beaucoup de thèmes et ça va dire que
maintenant on espère que la france avec
toute sa puissance plus vraiment avancer
les lois et l'initiative européenne dans
beaucoup beaucoup des domaines alors la
honte respectais beaucoup
de plus de visibilité sur 6 tirs et
chant international il ya le thème de
changement climatique bien sûr où la
france a aussi un forte rôle à jouer et
prendre l'union européenne avec alors là
c'est un grand programme qui nous attend
et bien sûr ça va clairement donné
beaucoup plus de visibilité
dans l'union européenne mais aussi je
pense en france propre on va parler
beaucoup plus des choses européenne des
questions qui sont un peu plus grand que
la france comme pays
petite question aussi notamment sur les
élections présidentielles qui vont
arriver donc on avril 2022 en france ça
ton pendant ce semestre de présidence
quel impact ça peut avoir justement
a bien sûr peut-être l'attention d'un
chef de gouvernement de diviser on peut
dire par exemple quand mon pays la
république tchèque a eu la présidence la
dernière fois on a subi une crise
politique et le gouvernement est tombé
pendant la présidence tchèque alors ce
n'était pas un bon une bonne carte de
visite
mais quand même on a beaucoup des gens
qui gèrent la quotidien il a des
ministres qui sont et des diplomates à
bruxelles bien sûr qu'ils sont
qui gère la machinerie alors là je pense
c'est c'est pas nécessairement trop
difficile même s'il ya si on a des
élections dans un pays
parce que on est on est sur les dossiers
qui sont étaient déjà présenté avant on
les travaille on travaille sur les
dossiers alors l'administration est bien
capable de continuer un travail comme ça
alors on va parler dans un instant
justement du lien avec la maison jean
monnet mais juste avant l'union
européenne elle est parfois perçue comme
lourdes et bureaucratiques mais pourtant
elle se retrouve dont la vie quotidienne
des français être dans les yvelines ya
beaucoup d'action qui sont destinées qui
sont portées par les financements
européens
c'est le cas de la politique d'insertion
du département ou encore des dispositifs
de mobilité pour les jeunes et je vous
propose de découvrir ce reportage les
explications de nicolas landry céline
charles et bixente mérian cette entité
ban là dessus
la mobilité européenne une action
visible par les jeunes yvelinois c'est
la mission du bureau d'information
jeunesse à montigny le bretonneux
ce centre départemental d'information
auprès des jeunes est labellisé euros
desk un point d'entrée destiné aux
jeunes pour des projets erasmus plus ou
de volontariat financé par l'union
européenne il ya quand même des fonds
qui sont dédiés à la mobilité des jeunes
et qui sont pas forcément toujours très
connue de ces jeunes erasmus plus c'est
un
indice positif donc là ça vient de
redémarrer 2021 et 2027 il y a des
beaucoup d'argent qui est dédié
justement le coup de pouce pour que les
jeunes puissent partir comme je vous
disais qu'ils soient stagiaires
étudiants jeunes travailleurs demandeurs
d'emploi ou même volontaire pour pour
pouvoir avoir une expérience à
l'étranger autre exemple de présence
d'actions européennes dans les yvelines
destiné à un public ciblé la politique
d'insertion du département un ensemble
d'actions porté par l' agence activités
en collaboration avec différents acteurs
de l'emploi sur le territoire des
mesures financées en partie par le fonds
social européen
c'est des cycles d'appel à projet de
trois ans sur deux cycles d'appels à
projets et sur deux grandes missions ses
4 millions d'euros qui est de fonds
sociaux européens qui ont été captées
pour à la fois payés les finances et les
personnels qui sont à l'accompagnement
de ces publics qui sont en recherche
d'insertion mais c'est aussi pour le
département la sécurisation de toutes
les associations qui font des demandes
de fonds sociaux européens danse dans
cette même politique et la politique
d'insertion entre 2014 et 2020 le
département des yvelines a piloté une
enveloppe de 16 millions d'euros en
provenance du fonds social européen
alors on disait un pavel chernov vous
faites partie de la maison de l'europe
dont les yvelines la maison de l'europe
c'est un relais de proximité un peu des
projets européens si j'ai bien compris
donc là on vient de voir des exemples
d'actions européennes développer sur le
territoire comment vous vous intervenez
comment on fait pour développer
finalement cessé projet européen au sein
d'un territoire comme celui des yvelines
alors il faut d'abord dire nous sommes
pas la maison d'europe mais nous sommes
la maison j'aime mon nez dans la maison
privée ou jean monnet le père fondateur
d'europe premier citoyen d'honneur
d'europe habitait la maison et un musée
on peut visiter chaque jour en
organisent des événements pour les
groupes scolaires pour des visiteurs et
à côté de cette maison on a créé une
académie ça s'appelle l'académie jean
monnet pour former des fonctionnaires de
l'union européenne bce spécifiquement
les fonctionnaires du parlement européen
parce que la maison jean monnet
appartient au parlement européen et on a
des collègues de bruxelles luxembourg de
strasbourg qui vient réguler herman pour
des séminaires de trois jours pour ses
formes et pour en fait serait connecté
avec les racines de ces projets
européenne avec l'idée qu'ils étaient
conçus dans le jardin de cette maison
c'était un mail messin 1950 où jean
monnet et robert schuman
est sonné de bernard clapiers ont fait
en fait ils ont créé le texte de la
déclaration de robert schuman qui était
la fondation de
rop min alors si vous cherchez un
endroit pour se reconnecter avec les
racines avec une idée d'origine c'est
chez nous et c'est ça fonctionne très
très bien parce qu'on a vraiment un
endroit magique où on peut voir comme
jean monnet à travailler et on peut
c'est très interactif aussi notre
exposition qu'on a là dans la maison
dont on peut vraiment passé à une jolie
après-midi et reconnecter avec cette
idée parce que en fait il faut dire
qu'aujourd'hui l'europe d'aujourd'hui
c'est en aidant on donnerait de la
monnaie c'est quelque chose qui était
réglée pendant les générations et nous
sommes aujourd'hui donc quelque chose
qui est déjà là vous avez bien dit que
parfois les gens perçoit lignes
européennes comme celui des choses
administrative est lourd mais en fait la
réalité est totalement différente que
qu'on a une europe avec des
frontières ouvertes et on travaille
ensemble et beaucoup d'administrations
qui était bouger vers bruxelles n'existe
plus dans les pays membres parce que
c'est pas nécessaire alors fait une
division de travail et
élargie on a commencé avec six pays au
début et aujourd'hui on est 27
c'est vraiment si vous regardez ça d'une
pompe du générationnel c'est fascinant
et pour les jeunes aujourd'hui ça donne
beaucoup beaucoup d'opportunités de
voyager de faire ces étudiants étrangers
de trouver du boulot dans notre pays d
oc de ses développeurs de développer
avec ses
avec ses propres facilité alors là et en
plus dans les yvelines vous pouvez
visiter touché sept projets
ce combiné chaîne va en tout cas assez
noter pour la maison jean monnet merci
beaucoup pavel sert notch d'avoir été
avec nous je le rappelle bien sûr vous
êtes et je vous souhaite une bonne
présidence avec notre petit
symbole tchèque pour la présidence à
venir s'y faire et je le rappelle vous
êtes historien conférencier à l'académie
donc jean monnet également un peu
représentant yves binois du parlement
européen merci beaucoup d'avoir été là
on ne badine pas avec les traditions
cette année encore la galette des rois
fait son grand retour chez nos
boulangers l'épiphanie c'est demain et
nos commerçants se préparent activement
pour pouvoir proposer une galette
feuilletée maison à tous les habitants
céline charles a rencontré l'équipe la
flûte de chopin à houdan regarder après
la bûche de noël place à la
traditionnelle galette des rois tous les
ans ce sont près de 2000 galettes
préparées sur le mois de janvier dans
cette boulangerie à houdan c'est une
tradition
ces
gâteaux
de début d'année qui passe bien qui
réunit les gens qui aujourd'hui est
compliquée pour les réunir mais ouais je
pense que c'est le gâteau un peu festif
pour réunir les gens souhaiter la bonne
année j'aime bien la tradition et la
tranche est un essai
si l'occasion se réunir et de faire la
fête la méthode est artisanale
un exercice qui demande une grande
précision car ici on ne plaisante pas
avec la galette après la préparation de
la pâte qui doit reposer une journée la
confection demande une précision
chirurgicale
à commencer par la garniture ou d'un
monde farine
e
beurre sucre glace chantier et rome
[Musique]
le lendemain du coup après avoir l'avoir
mis en sac je vais lui donner quatre
tours dans la journée donc deux tours
ainsi que deux au tour 2 heures après
que le temps que la pâte propose bien et
le lendemain ensuite je lui donne un
cinquième tome je procédais du coup on
détache des galettes une fois toutes les
galettes sont détaillées sur le patron
je vais les mettre sur gris et les
stocker au frigo une petite demi-heure
avant de les garnir pour la galette à
l'eau ce qui va permettre
aux deux disques de feuilletage de
scolaires entre eux et ensuite on va
procéder au gain ni sage
[Musique]
la sphère mise en place là je procéder à
la soudure beaucoup des galettes donc ce
sens rien de plus et on les colle juste
entré c'est le mot qui va faire le reste
du travail et ensuite un petit coup de
dos
[Musique]
cette année la galette a une
particularité en plus elle est solidaire
qui nos clients une femme de tels
restaurateurs il se présente qui chez le
restaurateur le restaurateur pour lui
offre le pas
le cocktail de bienvenue pour le repas
qui sera consommée chez lui lorsqu'on
voit même une petite fête en fête le
client aura du coup une petite remise de
10% en fait sur le choix sur le sur la
pièce de son choix en ce moment je suis
un commerçant vous voilà vous avez un
avantage chez un autre et je trouve que
c'est hyper important surtout dans une
petite ville comme la nôtre consommer
artisanale et locales tout en mangeant
un produit de qualité un cocktail qui
ravit les clients comme les boulangers
qui peuvent faire jusqu'à 10 % de
chiffre d'affaires supplémentaire sur
cette période
on en parlait en début de semaine le fc
versailles s'est qualifié ce dimanche 2
janvier dernier pour les huitièmes de
finale de la coupe de france victoire à
4 à 0 contre la roche vendée globe et
versailles connaît après à présent son
adversaire il s'agira de toulouse
bixente mayence insisté ban journalistes
de la rédaction vous êtes là pour nous
décrypter ce tirage bonsoir bonsoir je
sais alors comment on réagit finalement
les versailles et 1 quand ils ont appris
cet adversaire alors l'entraîneur
youssef chibi l'avait dit en conférence
de presse à l'issue de la rencontre du
week-end dernier que ce soit bergerac
l'autre petit poucet de la coupe ou le
paris saint-germain danseurs et
aborderait la rencontre de la même
manière pour les joueurs c'est différent
on avait senti qu'ils voulaient se
frotter aux plus grandes écuries de
ligue 1 peut-être donc un peu de
déception mais malgré tout l'impatience
de se confronter au haut niveau écoutez
la réaction de oussama berkak le
capitaine de l'équipe pour moi c'est un
bon tirage c'est quand même l'équipe
professionnelle comme comme vous l'avez
dit c'est sa jolie au tableau en ligue 2
c'est offensivement c'est très fort
c'est sûr qu'on aurait aimé et un gros
d'hier pour le public les supporters
pour la ferveur mais bon c est comme une
équipe professionnelle et ce minerai
soit sonic contre c'est toujours
intéressant et donc c'est vers celle qui
évoluera à domicile oui l'interrogation
c'est est ce que le club pourrait voler
dans son antre le stade mont boron qui
pourrait a priori accueillir la joueuse
fixé à 5000 spectateurs il faut savoir
que l'éclairage du stade mais pas aux
normes pour recevoir une telle affiche
si l'horaire de la rencontre est fixée
en journée ce sera donc possible si
c'est en soirée il faudra trouver une
autre arène dans les parages quoi qu'il
en soit à l'écart sur le papier sera le
même deux divisions versailles assume ce
statut d'outsider et y croit ça va un
match comme les autres c'est 90 minutes
surtout capable prolongation ça vaut
plati dr tout peut se passer on a vu et
on a vu cette année en coupe de france
dn3 qui tape de dire
pourquoi pas nous surtout qu'à
versailles à l'époque ils ont déjà fait
ont déjà tapé dijon 1-0 et les ipad sur
penalty c'est pas impossible
alors là oussama berkak fait référence à
un huitième tour disputé en 2009 c'est
le dernier exploit en date du fc
versailles dans cette coupe une victoire
dont 1 0 grâce à un penalty de grégory
lefort à la 71ème minute malheureusement
le club ne parviendra pas à passer le
tour suivant depuis ceux qui suivent le
football amateur saf le club est
ambitieux il veut se donner les moyens
daly maj de son nouvel actionnaire
principal le promoteur immobilier et
constructeurs fille du sim city arriver
au printemps 2000 20 heures qui a nommé
récemment l'ancien footballeur et
consultant jean luc arribart au poste de
directeur général pour marquer le
changement on parle donc d'un club qui a
multiplié son budget par 5 quand même de
quoi recruter de nouveaux joueurs l'été
dernier
plus de la moitié ou plus de la moitié
de
l'effectif et les nouveaux et c'est vrai
qu'il ya six mois on se connaissait pas
et faire ce qu'on fait là six mois après
c'est beau maintenant ce serait bien que
de continuer en championnat assez si on
peut valider tout ça sur la deuxième
partie de championnat serait magnifique
pour les choix des nouveaux joueurs
c'est l'entraîneur youssef chebbi qui
était donc aux commandes la plupart
connaissent bien la division actuelle de
versailles la nationale 2 changez 80%
dans l'effectif on dit toujours dans le
football que c'est un pari risqué au
moment cela paye en championnat puisque
versailles est bien parti pour monter
reste à voir si cette équipe laissera
une trace d'elle à l'échelle du pays de
la coupe de france
et ça ce sera le week-end du 29 janvier
c'est la date est dix huitième de finale
de coupe de france face à toulouse merci
bixente mayence entité ban est d'avoir
été avec nous journalistes pour la
rédaction
toujours côté sport on parle un cyclisme
à présent le parcours du paris nice 2022
a été dévoilée ce mercredi 5 janvier à
versailles le départ sera donné le 6
mars depuis les yvelines pour la
treizième année consécutive les
cyclistes vont faire une boucle dans le
département au départ de mantes la ville
le lendemain comme d'habitude c'est une
petite commune du département qui
accueillera le départ de l'épreuve cette
année c'est auffargis qui sera qui aura
ce privilège
un village de moins de 2000 habitants et
on écoute le responsable du tracé
françois lemarchand au micro de michael
et une vidéo moi même quand je quand je
courais chez les amateurs je cours
beaucoup auffargis donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui qui qui parle au
milieu cycliste il ya beaucoup de 2,2
groupe cycliste qui font du vélo tous
les week ends dans cette vallée de
chevreuse qui passaient auffargis donc
un petit clin d'oeil aux farges et c'est
sympa c'est la fin de ce journal merci à
tous de nous avoir suivi dans un instant
retrouver mélanie poké à la présentation
de votre 7,8 société très bonne soirée à
tous sur tv 78 et prenez soin de vous
[Musique]